All right. Good morning. Let us begin.
Today we're going to move away from the
first dimension of music that we've been
looking at,
which is duration or time and begin to
work with the second which is pitch and
melody. And here's an uh, uh,
an initial question for you.
Think of the texture of music and think
of this, these strands of high and low.
Where does melody sit in the texture?
Is it high,
middle, or low? Where is it you
think about it conceptually,
I'm trying to figure out,
well, I got this board up here,
this tapestry or whatever. Where's my
melody going to be in the texture? High,
middle or low? Michael? Yeah, usually hot.
Now here's an interesting question
for you. Why is it usually hot?
There's an acoustical reason for this.
Why does the melody show up in
the high range? I beg your pardon.
It's easier to hear in a high range.
Why is it easier to hear in a high range?
What about the acoustics here?
Once again,
laws of acoustics.
Why is it easier to hear in a high
range? I could play for you. For example,
a little bit of Mozart with
something like this. Yeah.
You like that
sounds better up there. It doesn't.
Why is that the case? Yeah,
that's it. Exactly. In a melody, we tend
to have a lot of rhythmic activity there.
It's got to have activity to
play itself out as melody melody,
but because the way a
sound waves operated,
we have these low sound waves taking
a very long time to clear everything,
very long time to clear.
The higher frequencies take a lot shorter
time to clear their short sound waves.
They clear very quickly
so we can hear a melody,
we can hear a melody more clearly in this
higher register and therefore there is
always the tendency to have
the base plate sort of walls,
low notes because those sounds take a
long time to clear and melodies play
faster rhythms because those sounds clear
quickly and we can hear and enjoy the
melody. All right. That's just a,
an opening thought about why melody
show up in the top part of the texture.
Let's talk about melody here
and let's talk about pitch.
We said before that in western music
we have musical notation and musical
notation has relied on more in western
music and any other musical civilization
around the world.
And in the west,
this whole idea of pitch notation goes
back to the ninth century when the monks
and nuns in Benedictine abbeys in
Switzerland and France and Germany,
northern Italy started doing this.
They started marking on parchment or
slate the general course of a military.
Eventually what they did
was to separate these
lines into more discreet places,
are more discreet pitches.
Then around 1000 in northern Italy and
enterprising fellow named Guido hereto
came along and said, well,
you know what? I can,
I can get this to show us how far up we
are supposed to go by placing it on some
kind of grid here. And this is
this, this, uh, as I say before,
at the beginning of the first
graph in the history of the West,
this grid of horizontal lines.
And we will know that if
we're going from here to here,
it's got to be exactly this
frequency or at least this space.
So initially they came up with four
lines and eventually five and even six,
and then they went back to
five by the 15th century.
What they also did around the
year 1000 was to identify,
to label these, uh, particular, uh, spots,
spaces in line. So they began to
call this a and this B and this, c,
d and e, this, f this, g.
When they got up here,
they stop.
Why did they stop?
Why didn't they keep right on going
with g h? I, j. K. L. M. N. O. P.
Why don't we sing m's and o's and peas
today?
Why did they stop?
Any ideas?
Yeah,
no, they had this thing, they hit this
thing called the octave. Then of course,
there's this at and another acoustical
phenomena here we've talked about before.
What's your relationship within an octave?
The string is vibrating higher.
One is exactly twice
with the lower on the,
so they heard this and they heard
this is essentially all one sound.
So if it's a duplication of sale,
let's duplicate the letters.
But you can't look at manuscripts of
the early 11th century and see it was
people singing peas and L's and
ooze and ends and things like that.
So they became to uniformly adopted
system of what's called octave duplication
and every musical
culture around the world.
I've talked with ethnomusicologists
about this particular point.
Every musical culture around the
world, Chinese, Japanese, Indonesian,
Indian, African, whatever,
they all use this phenomenon of Optus
duplication in their music, octave,
duplication in the music.
But how they divide up this sonic
space within the active can vary rather
considerably.
Some Arabic music seems to have as many
as 14 gradations within the opposite.
Now we're going to listen to a piece
of music here from the tradition of
classical India and I thought we
might have a sitar player in here.
Somebody I got wind of the fact,
we might have the classical
Indian musician in our class,
somebody that has studied the Sitar and
might be able to come in and play one
for us, but we don't, we don't have that.
So we're going to use a something
on our CD's by the world.
Famous sitarist Ravi Shankar.
Okay. You've probably heard of him.
He's actually quite old though.
It must be surely isn't as eighties.
He was very famous when I was in graduate
school. Tons and tons of years ago. So,
but he is the venerable sitar player.
And here is the pattern of the Raga,
we'll call it a scale.
It's not really a skill but a
but a raga that he is using.
It's got only six notes within the office
and the sick notes are
that particular pattern.
It doesn't sound like any skill
you we've ever heard of it.
So let's listen to Ravi Shankar play a
bit of a Raga using a six node scale.
Okay?
Okay.
So that gives you a flavor of that and
you have that of course on your CD number
six 15. Uh, so that's um, that's a,
a bit of Sitar music. Now we're going
to play another six nodes scale.
Let's go onto that one.
Linda gets set and this of
course is sung by Norah Jones.
And as you know from reading the textbook,
why do I mention Norah Jones?
Or why do we play Norah Jones right
after Ravi Shankar? It's his daughter.
No,
an interesting world.
Every Saturday morning and
I'm going through stop and
shoppers and there is Nora
Jones and the background playing and I'm
going down the pasta aisle or whatever
and I have the daughter of Ravi Shankar
over my, over my shoulder. What a world.
Huh?
Uh,
so we're going to listen to just a
couple of seconds here of a blues tune by
some by Norah Jones.
Okay. So we'll just cut. But
what she's working losses people,
we're not going to listen to the
whole thing is this idea of a book.
Yeah.
No.
How's that up? Right? One,
two, three, four, five, six.
With this one, sometimes major in,
sometimes minor, we'll come back to it.
So that's another six notes scale,
but a different sort of pattern.
A different kinds of pattern
is a blues scale pattern.
Just kind of between the major
and minor that we'll, we'll,
we'll talk about a little bit later.
So two different forms of a six node
pattern. Let's go to a five no pattern.
If you've ever visited parts of Indonesia,
which I have not.
And if you've ever visited parts
of China, which I have not, um,
I am told that you will
hear this kind of music.
It's played by a traditional Chinese
instrument called the are who this I have
seen around the world many times and
heard it's a two string instrument to
produce a particularly beautiful,
vibrant tone.
So we're going to listen
to an r who playing.
I think this is track if
you want to pursue it,
it's track a six CD track 16.
Um,
let's listen to an r who play a melody
by a traditional Chinese composer.
We call him an English Abi and you can
read about him there in your textbook.
Okay,
so let's pick that up.
Five notes within the octave just there.
So it's a pen and what we call a
pentatonic scale pentatonic scale.
And that's using a lot of, of Far Eastern
cultures, the pentatonic scale to five,
five note scale. Yeah. Okay. So we have
this whole idea of octave duplication,
uh, sometimes six months,
sometimes five notes.
We in the West have settled on a seven
note scale. Why did that happen? Well,
we have this idea of the seven oaks
major seven no,
the
notes, well, if the answer that we have
to go back to ancient Greek music theory,
and you read about this as really, really
turgid stuff, but believe it or not,
I teach a course on this at the graduate
level. We have to read the quarter.
Linda has to take this kind of stuff from
reading era stocks and this and things
like this. So what, what we were
dealing here with is a situation.
The ancient Greeks were very much into
mathematics as a way of explaining the
world and explaining music in particular
and they thought these ratios were
primary.
So they had the ratio of two to one,
which gave them the
octave and three to two,
which gave them the fifth and four
to three, which gave them the fourth.
They also, because the system worked
out better for their purposes,
then jumped to nine to eight,
which gave them the whole time.
So they started out there and let's
say they were working down here,
they filled in the octave up above and
then they filled in the fifth and then
they filled in the fourth and then they
came down a whole step and then they
went up a fourth from that whole
step and an upper forth from that.
And they were filling in in this
fashion interestingly enough.
And you ever wonder this I,
there's sometimes if somebody
wandered by keyboards,
that's odd. What's the great
oddity about the keyboard?
Which strange about this keyboard?
It's very a symmetrical right? Uh, Marcus.
Yeah, it's missing. It's missing
some, some notes in here.
This is missing something in
here and there's missing there.
Well what these are where the cracks
after the Greeks laid out their fists and
force and whole steps,
they had these little leftovers.
They called them lemurs are,
they had these little leftovers in there
and that's why we end up with these
small distances between BNC.
Yeah. Hot, hot, hot.
That's a big step out. Hum.
Badadada that's
a small step there.
So the scale is actually not equal.
A to B is one distance, which
is a large one. And BDC is,
is only half that distance.
And that's because of the way the Greeks
laid this thing out with their two to
one ratio, street to ratios and
so on. But in any event we in,
we ended up with this. Now the Greeks,
so had a whole series of patterns.
They called them mixed
of Lydian and hypo mix,
the Lydian and Phrygian and hypo
fridges and stuff like this.
A lot of different patterns.
But in the course of history,
we settled beginning in the 16th and
17th century down into two just two
patterns than what we call the
major pattern and the minor pattern.
So let's talk about that just for
a moment. Uh, and before we do it,
I should add one of the things. How then
do we get these other notes up here?
We get these other notes up here.
Well, well we now call the black notes,
although historically
keyboards could be either way.
You could have these added notes,
a black oral, uh, or white,
and then these underneath would be buying.
So we filled these out sort
of in the 14th century.
All of this got filled in.
These between BNC and enf didn't get
filled in because they were already just
the smallest amount that they wanted
to deal with. Just half steps.
So we end up here within an octave.
We end up with 12 equal pitches,
but we still use this term a seven note
scale because we have seven notes within
the scale of the major scale and seven
notes within the scale of the minor scale.
All right,
so let's talk about major and minor now
and we've put those patterns up here.
This is given for you in your
textbook is something of a review.
Let's start with a major scale on a c.
So here is the symbol for c and the staff.
Here is where c would be
located on the keyboard.
We're going to start here and we had this
pattern of the major that goes whole,
whole half, whole, whole, whole half step.
So we start on c and then
we go up to d a whole step.
I'm going to write that in here.
That's good.
Now we go d to e and
that's another whole step.
Now I have a half step. I got to go
up just a half step there and money,
but it's just f is just a half step away,
so that's good.
I don't need to do anything more
than that. Now I'm on f here. Oil,
I need a whole step. There's
my one, I need a whole step.
I got to go up to g and then another
whole step up to a and then another whole
step up to be.
And the last one in the major
pattern is a half step from B to c.
Ah,
there we are and that's good.
So we've got our major scale. Let's
talk a little bit about the minor scale.
Now it's got it. It's got a different
pattern, got a different pattern.
They liked melodies to go this way.
They're like melodies to go this way.
Let's start on the same pitch.
See,
let's go up a whole step.
What's a whole step above c?
Just d now we need according to our
pattern to go up just a half step.
What's a half step above d?
Well then we have to think about,
we've got to get into these black notes,
which can be called sharps or flats.
They're called sharps.
If they're up above the note in question,
this would be some kind
of d sharp. They're called
flats if they're down below.
So flats or below, uh, the
sharps take you up a half step.
So we went to see two D, we need this
pitch here. What are we going to call it
or are we going to call it d sharp?
Well we should call it e flat.
We should call it e flat
and put it up on the Elan.
Cause it was kind of a rule here that you
have to use up each letter name intern
each letter name. In turn we can't
go. C, d, d sharp, f we got to go CD,
some kind of e f so you gotta go
up the alphabet here. All right,
so there we are.
But is this from d to e a half step?
We need a half step here.
What we've written is a whole step.
So we've got to indicate that this is
just a half step away in that fashion.
D to e flat.
Now what do we do above the flat?
Well, the whole step here
where there's one half,
there's another hand would take us to
f whole step above f would take us to,
Gee, what am I going to
write here from, Gee,
I need a half step here is ah,
it doesn't matter. Here's the pattern
up here. We'll focus on this one.
I need a half step above g. What's
a half step above g? E flat.
Okay.
I need a whole step above a flat,
right?
Hmm. Nice and loud please.
Edward B flat. Okay.
And then at the end of the process,
I have another whole step from B flat back
to seat. And that gives me back to my,
to my active in that fashion.
Okay.
Well I think that's a
straightforward enough if,
if you're unsure about that checkout, of
course, chapter three in the textbook, uh,
where these issues, uh,
issues are addressed.
Okay. We've been talking about scales,
these idea of major and minor scales,
and we said there's seven notes
in each of these two scales,
12 pitches altogether within the office.
But within the scale,
all notes are not the same. There's
one note as the primary note, right?
What's the primary node call? They'll
note around which all of the others,
all the others gravitate tonic. No. Okay.
Uh, then there's one other
that we have to know about.
It's called the leading tone
and what it does is pull in the,
to the tonic.
Let's say we're in the key of c here.
The leading tone is always the seventh
degree. It's always a half step,
or it's a half snap. Seventh degree
right below, right below the tonic.
We might throw it away, man. I thought the
tonic was down here. We've got one, two,
three, four, five, six, seven and eight.
Eight is a duplication of
one eat in one or the tonic.
So seven poles up in two,
eight it pulls up into
two eight the tonic.
Hmm.
That's the leading toe.
Where's it want to go?
You can hear it pulling in their
opera. Singers love this. They,
they love to kind of luxuriate and the
opportunity to show off their voice on
leading tones, build up expectation.
Make you wait even more for that topic.
Let's listen to Luciano Pavarotti.
Pavarotti seeing a leading tone and it
was by coincidence happens to be the one
year anniversary of the Pavarotti,
his death this week.
So here's Luciano Pavarotti,
singing, leading tone.
The tempo here is very slow and
he slows it down even more than,
and he just sits out there,
this huge wonderful voice that
he had on the leading tone.
And you can hear him sort of slightly,
didn't go,
gone. You could hear him slide
that leading towed into the,
into the, um, into the
tonic in that case. Okay.
So we've got across the idea of,
uh,
of tonics and leading tones.
So we do tonics.
Do we know the time it is?
Sing it. Um, so given the setup,
you kind of feel that what your Michigan
or what this home home pitch is the
pitch to which to which
you are Greg gravitating
most of our popular music folk tall or
songs or things like that are written in
Dupo meter and in a major key.
Occasionally you get things written
in triple meter and in a minor key,
minor key.
Yeah.
Uh,
that's Gershwin,
Porgy and bess in minor folks home.
Well, civil war, civil war
zone and so on. It goes.
Occasionally you do run into pop pieces,
folk songs in minor,
but most of them are in major,
probably about 80% in major.
Same thing in the classical
realm. Linda, what would you say?
What percentage of classical
pieces are written in minor keys?
Okay,
well, well give us a number. Take
only five. Classical. Huh? Maybe
a little more than that, but,
but, but not, not all that minute.
Here's what I don't know. We should,
we should do a survey sometime. Go to
go through the literature, see what,
but most of, for the most part, it shows
minor. A major occasionally is chosen.
Here's a good example of a minor from
the second movement of Beethoven's Third
Symphony.
Hmm.
No,
but for Mozart,
major
difference between major and minor.
So when you used to making
associations with major and
minor, major, happy, bright,
optimistic day, like today, minor, somber.
Uh, why is that the case? Is there
anything in the physics of this music? No,
not really.
There's nothing in the loss of physical
acoustics here that caused that to be
the case.
If you look back over it,
there was no prejudice major or minor
in western music up in about the 16th
century.
And then people started writing these
things called madrigals that were tied to
texts and they got in this habit of
every time they had a bright happy texts,
they'd set this in one kind of,
uh, of mode or, or key major,
a major mode. And every time it had
a sad, when they'd set it in minor,
we got used to hearing it that way.
So it's kind of cool every time it'll
shoe wants to write about the Mary Farmer.
Sometimes she'll buy,
let's right a funeral march.
And there's a tendency also minor, low,
major high trying to say, so we get,
we get used to this and this point that
it is culture rather than acoustics was
brought home to me once in a discussion
with a student here at Yale who said to
me, yeah, but over there
at the [inaudible] center,
we Jews have lots of happy melodies and
they are all in minor what you would
call minor. That's what I
thought about that. Yeah,
that's probably true even though,
hmm.
It's that the Israeli national anthem.
I think so.
Is that right? What, is
that what yes or no? Okay.
But it may be how many national anthems
around the world do we have in minor
keys? And what does this say about the
tradition of Jewish music? He, is it,
is it really western or is
it eastern European or Asian?
Even with some Asian influences.
Ah, interesting. Interesting issues,
uh, issues that can be brought
home. This kind of ambiguity.
Sometimes you encounter in Klezmer
music, any, but what's Klezmer music,
sort of Jewish,
traditional Jewish folk music.
A lot of the coming out of eastern Europe.
So we're going to listen to a kind of
souped up or rocked up a version of some
klezmer music here and what they have
a strong bass electric bass underneath.
And we're going to listen
to
a minor melody with the
leading tone thrown in.
It gives it this kind of exotic field
and then it will switch
major.
So let's listen to this
bit of Klezmer music.
Go back and forth between minor and major
[inaudible].
Okay.
Okay, so that's the intro. Now we're
going to go onto the shift. Uh,
two major here,
another little clip.
So there is in major,
let's listen a little bit more.
It's going to go back to minor and then
I think shifts back to major will be a
boon to hear. You're the shift turned
down just a little bit. Linda, please.
Major, minor. Raise your left
hand if you think it's minor.
What about this major? My right
hand, if it's major, this is major.
It's a little bit of a, of this
ambiguity in between major and minor.
Any piece of traditional Jewish music.
Oh,
let's see.
We've talked about.
Let's talk about hearing. Tell me
how we hear these melodies. Um,
when the reason that we hear these
is this as distinctly different,
I think happens rather
early on in the scale.
Let's think about this for a minute.
We've got this scale up. Can we?
Yeah. Um, if you go to this scale
that sound dark, I don't know, 500 years
ago, that wouldn't have sounded dark.
Now that sounds dark to us,
Ahmed,
Yamaha, Yamaha, Tom,
but that darkness occurs very early
in the scale. As you can see there.
It's the third note we'll be talking
about the fact that this is an interval of
the third spans,
three letter names a little bit later
on so that minor third can show up very
early in the scale that that's a critical
moment in any scale determining how
we're going to feel about it
and we can just play with that.
That particular interval to change
entirely the way we feel about particular
melodies here is I'm a Christian song.
I guess it's
joy to the world.
The Lord has come.
Don't we send you the Christmas Kale or
something is seen as a Christmas Carol.
Not much joy there. Oh, you
like that one. How about you?
Or my favorite is
no,
you can turn this whole thing.
You said Jewish bar Mitzvah or
something like that. And you were,
you were singing with the Coen brothers
down to somewhere in an appellation.
What was that wonderful movie though?
But it had the Coen brothers and all
the great American folk music in it.
You are my sunshine. Oh,
brother. Where art thou?
Wasn't that what it was called
brother? Where art thou? Yeah. So, uh,
just that little was a switch to
turn off a switch there. You can,
you can do some great, great things
with changing, changing the mode.
So we've got scales that
are in the major mode.
We've got scales in the minor mode.
We also have scales in the chromatic mode,
and that's when we don't have just
seven pitches within this scale.
We're going to use all of the pitches,
all 12 here,
chroma from the is the Greek
word for color. So this is a,
a more colorful scale. Um, uh,
what is it?
Well,
that's a chromatic scale.
We had an example of that the other
day working with the Mozart. Uh,
where was that in the requiem. Oh, food.
Yeah. Remember we had, he
was coming up a minor stuff,
gale
and then he at the top
love it,
switched over into a chromatic scale.
Here's the story.
Minor
chromatic,
um, what does, what does this do to us?
Why did he do that?
Well,
it chromaticism adds tension to music and
especially chromaticism that's pulling
up scales and go up ed tension
music goes up generally.
But if you can double that,
combine that with chromatic music,
then you got a sort of super windy of
tension and that's what he's doing.
They're trying to build tension as,
as the just rise from the graves at the,
at that party.
At that particular point,
the entire compositions are rarely
written in the chromatic scale.
Yeah.
It's,
it's kind of a color that you throw in
from time to time for a special effect.
So we've got the major minor scales,
we've got the chromatic scales.
We also have what we
call conjunct melodies.
Hmm.
Melodies or just kind of running up and
down the scale, a neighboring tones. Um,
those are two Christmas carols that
are very conjunct in, in nature.
A good example we used a moment
ago of a disjunct melody. Yes.
Hmm.
Can we all sing that?
Here we go, ready sing,
take me how to the ball game,
take me out to the park,
et,
etc. It's amazing that that melody has
become as popular as it has given the
fact that it's really hard to sing.
It's a very disjunct melody.
It's got all these odd leaps at Bop,
bop, bop, boop beep. So I was like, sure.
And Berg almost, it's sort of off the
map here in terms of this junk mis,
but nonetheless we have been
able to absorb all of that.
So melodies can be conjunct or this joke
and possibly the most conjunct of all
melodies.
And the history of music was the melody
that we looked at very briefly in the
first gathering and that is
Beethoven's famous Ode to Joy.
Now would the van Beethoven
was in his fifties,
when he was working on his last symphony,
would prove to be as last symphony,
his ninth symphony.
Uh,
and he'd been tinkering with
this particular melody all
the way back to probably
1803. So it's about 20 years
or so. Ninth Symphony is 18,
23, 24 as early as 1823.
We know he's working right?
Trying to get this to work just right.
And eventually over this 20 year period,
he did get it to work just right.
Let me swing this board around.
Here's the famous melody.
I put it in the key, uh,
what's called the Bass clef here.
And it's in a major key. Uh,
we don't need to know what
the particular notes are,
but let's look at this just
for a moment because it's,
it works well as a prototype of melody.
It does something that a lot
of melodies do. First of all,
as you can see by the trajectory here,
it's very conjunct,
right? It's all a
neighboring notes here. Uh,
if you look at the German and the text,
it has to do with xy.
UHMM shroom and nearly Yonin the
millions be embraced. And this I believe,
is that sort of national anthem
for the United Nations. So this,
this has to be something that we can all
see. And if you have conjunct motion,
that makes it easier.
It's also very symmetrical.
As you can see,
it's nothing but a pattern of four bars
plus four bars plus four bars plus four
bucks.
And as we said before,
music has a syntax so that these
phrases have to be in a price range in a
particular way. That makes sense. So we
start out here with an opening phrase.
No, hot, hot, hot, hot, hot, hot,
hot, hot, hot, hot, hot, hot, hot.
Is that the tonic dot.
Yeah.
MMM.
Gained by seeing the tonic. Yeah. Yeah.
The tonic is actually over here.
It's a little bit lower than that.
That was a really hard question and that
is amazing that anybody got it. Good.
Phew. So what happens here
is this opening phrase it,
we'll call a musicians like to label stuff
just with alphabetical labels to keep
it simple.
We'll call this phrase a,
it sort of opens things up and we
refer to this as the antecedent frig.
The next phrase be
a lot od Dadadadadada
very similar dot.
Yeah.
Aw.
But here it takes the a deviation.
Dot Hot
and gets it back.
Gets us back to the tonic.
Now we could walk out the door at
that point, right. Dot. Um, we've,
we're feeling totally stable there.
We've got an altogether for
the rest of the day. However,
it'd be a pretty short melody. So what
he then does is write an extension.
We'll call this c
yacht hot, hot, hot, hot, hot, hot, hot,
hot, hot, hot, hot, hot, hot, hot, hot.
Um, ah, very interesting.
Put an asterix by this.
Beethoven in a way saved this melody.
He rescued this melody,
which was in danger of becoming
excessively s four square by doing,
what if I had been writing it?
Todd Todd, Todd, Todd, Todd. Ah,
Dadada.
What did Beethoven do here?
We talked about it last time.
ARRHYTHMIC device syncopation.
He brings his opening note that f
sharp in a beat early. This should,
you would think would be a half note.
And this would start on
the down beat over here,
but he brings in effect the sounds
of the downbeat in a beat early.
It gives it a little bit of pep
there at that particular point.
And then what is this here long
you thought? Hot, hot, hot,
hot, hot, hot, hot tar. Tar Pop.
Well of course it's a replication of B.
We've got to end on the tonic.
All pieces of classical or pop one
way or the other and on the tonic.
Okay,
so lets us,
let's have us now for Moto over this.
Let's all sing this.
I think we don't have to read the note.
You don't have to sing any text. We're
just going to sing la all conduct in four.
So sit back.
Well my mama ma ha ha ha ha ha ha.
I believe vocally prepared
here. Here. Here we go.
I'll give you one, two. Ready Sing,
la La la La Louder loud.
Her La La la La la La la La la La la La
la La la La la La la La la La la La la
La la La la La la La la La la.
La,
la, la, la, la, la, la.
We'll
put a big retard on it. Yeah. So
we wanted to bang that syncopation.
And then of course there's no sound on
the downbeat over here to make the sake
of patient shake a patient work. So
that's the melody. It seem very simple.
It took Beethoven a long time to sort of
iron all this out and make this perfect
melody, the prototypical melody in
a way. And then, uh, in the, uh,
early 18,
20.
So you decided to incorporate this as
the main theme of the last movement,
the finale of his last symphony.
So this is some of the last music that
Beethoven wrote in the setting that we're
about to listen to. So let's
listen. We're not going to,
I think Linda has it said here.
We're going to hear the beginning of this
and he prejudice it presents this as a
series of eight or variation. So here
is the first presentation of our melody.
Nice and loud.
That's okay.
And then he repeats C and B.
Okay.
Okay. Now let's pause.
Let's pause it right there.
Now we're going to go onto the second
presentation of the team and I have three
questions for you as we do.
So where has the theme of
the Melody Gone here? Uh,
well it's a, is this a motive
or a theme, by the way?
See, it's not a motive is way too,
or was a good example of a theme.
It's way too long for a motive.
Motive would only go about four or five,
six months. So we had this
beautiful theme here. Um,
and as we listened to
this next presentation,
where has the theme or Melody Golan,
what instruments are playing at now?
Uh,
what is the texture?
Like how many lines can
you hear in this texture?
How many strands of music do you
hear? Can you pick up? And thirdly,
what is this texture call?
Last time we said we had three kinds of
texture and music, which are monophonic.
Homophonic can polyphonic which, uh,
is this particular texture. Okay,
here we go.
That's,
we should have an a
previous, yeah, it should be,
but that's the next variation. I
confused. I confused Linda there.
Here.
Great.
Let's just pause it there. So
what do you think, how many lines?
First of all, where's the
melody gone? The scene.
Okay.
It's gone up a little bit and it's
being played by what instruments? Yeah.
Strings, violins, violins. But not the
top. Not The top part of the violence.
Family kind of second violin,
middle range of the strings here.
How many parts do you hear in the, how
many separate musical lines there? Marcus?
Three. Tell us about those three.
We've just talked about one of them,
the melody and the violins up above.
Can you tell us about some of the others?
Oh,
okay. They're doing like a counterpoint,
right? They're doing it. Yeah.
Okay. This is, uh, it's too easy.
I'm sorry I had to go for that. Um,
uh, it, uh, there they are
playing a contrapuntal wall.
But you're absolutely right.
That's the key point. And that then
answers mark list. What's the texture?
If you got to cut Marcus please.
Yeah.
Polyphonic so this is polyphony here.
What was the third voice?
If we had melody up above
and kind of a counterpoint,
if Marcus says there in the middle,
what was the,
we had one other part and what was that?
Well,
let's listen to a little more. We've
identified the melody. Let's just,
can we just continue from
where we are? Okay. Maybe,
maybe you jumped ahead as I, as I told
you to do. Yeah. No, it's mine, don't you?
It's my fault,
not yours.
So we're going to back it up
into that previous variation.
Let's just see if we can pick up
what the missing third part here.
It's a bassoon playing the contrapuntal.
We'll
just pause it there.
So what is the third part there?
The base?
Yeah. Usually in Mel you're going to have
a melody. You're going to have a base.
So the base is doing stuff.
Hmm.
Underneath here. Um, so there,
there's the melody up above this
bassoon playing the counterpoint,
kind of in the middle.
And then the bass player needs
notes quietly underneath it.
There's a little bit hard to hear. A
little. I think we have time. Let's go.
Let's just continue right
from there a little bit more.
Can you hear the base now?
There's the bassoon counterpoint
and
let's listen to just a little bit.
I'm gonna pause it there.
Now let's listen to must be what?
The third presentation here of the
theme. Where's the theme now? Now,
how many parts are there in the texture?
Pause it right there. What about that?
What's a little bit hard to tell exactly?
Isn't it hard to tell?
What could you say for sure about it?
You've got a melody and where's
it going now? Well, it's going up.
It's all now in the first violins.
What else is in there?
Okay.
A base. Yeah, we've got a
base and now we, what else?
Some other stuff in the middle.
And that's,
that may be about as much as we can
do with that. I mean really, uh,
myself included. I could sort of
sit there and try to track lines,
but I'd have to repeat it. So I think
if we said, oh, we got, we got melody,
we've got theme, we got base, we've got
a bunch of other stuff in the middle.
That's just fine and dandy.
But the idea that did it all kind of
independent points out, once again,
that they are playing polyphonic texture.
Let's listen to the end of the polyphonic
texture then Beethoven and we'll,
we'll stop with this. It's Beethoven was
like a military general. Interesting.
The way he operated.
It's setting up these battles and indeed
he wrote something called the battle
symphony.
And you can just see him how he's kind
of marshaling particular forces to do
particular things at particular time.
So we kind of held back here,
the heavy artillery,
the heavy artillery in the orchestra is
what the brass and sometimes percussion.
So it's the brass he's going
to bring in at this point.
So we'll listen to the end of the
third presentation of this with the
contrapuntal idea, dominated
by strings, melody, base,
other stuff in the middle.
And then he will bring in the brass for
the final statement of this. And, uh,
I think our time is about up.
So we'll listen to this and you
can kind of go out as we hear the,
the fourth statement
[inaudible].